rewatch module one and you're going to have to learn that this is, it's honestly more of like a
gut feeling. There's not going to be specific things they're necessarily going to say. Sometimes
there will be, sometimes they'll say something, but most of the time it's what they're not saying
or they're just being too agreeable. Like I remember somebody posted a video in here of them
doing a hook, right? And the person just kept saying, yeah, that sounds good. Yeah. Okay. Cool.
Sounds good. And it was like, they just kept saying yes, because it was easier than saying no.
So it's more Nick, when you're listening to this, go watch module one, rewatch it.
I'm sorry, not module one, module four, go watch, go rewatch module four and, and do that. But the
other thing is I'll guarantee that this could solve 99% of your problems. Nick is just start making it
a habit. When you get to the end of that call and they sound interested and they keep going along
with you, do this, do the pullback. Hey, look, man, just want to double check, like happy to send
you a lead or two for free, but if that's all you're looking for, I'll still send it to you,
but I just want to be candid with you. I am looking to partner with somebody. So I just
want to make sure we're going to be good to talk in a couple of days. Is that cool? And if they,
if at that point you're giving them an out and if they're like, well, actually I'm actually pretty
busy, like, like double commit them, pull back. Like I don't care if you don't want to talk,
just tell me I'm a big boy. I'm a big girl. I don't need you to just, you know, kiss my
ass. Tell me the truth. So that, I think Nick, the real question here, I know what you're dealing
with. Start doing the pullback every single time and you're going to start, you're going to start
getting the not serious people out. And maybe these people, some of these are serious, but just
because of the, you're acting timid to ask that question. Um, they're, they're just going along
with you and then they're, they're kind of pushing them away. So try that. I think that
will solve a lot of your problems.